well good morning Ted this my name is
John Hodgman as you may know I am a
famous and minor television personality
they have brought to speak to you today
you may know that I do occasional
commentary on The Daily Show with Jon
Stewart as their resident expert and
while I am not trained as a comedian I
have learned from working on The Daily
Show that the best time to do comedy is
Sunday morning at 8:00 a.m. the
comedian's professional comedians call
it the magic hour it's actually when we
tape The Daily Show in fact we we wake
up early on a Sunday morning around 4
o'clock Jon Stewart makes a mess of
flapjacks some cowboy coffee we get down
we write the jokes by about 8 o'clock
we're ready to go
we have to rouse the audience from the
dormitory where we keep them there
usually they're usually not warmed up as
we say in the comedy industry so we have
to bring out a comedian to tell them a
few jokes warm them up and we also have
to inject them with massive doses of
epinephrine directly in the heart that's
how we get them going by then we're off
to the races
unfortunately DEA would not allow me to
inject your hearts with epinephrine this
morning so I hope the coffee will do the
trick
I have laced it with methamphetamine
you may also know that I appear in a
series of television advertisements for
the Apple computer company we're doing
we do these advertisements for
human-shaped computers I think I'm not
really sure
some kind of androids I don't know I
don't keep up with the technology when I
when I am old-fashioned when I need a
human-shaped computer I just hire a
mentat now at this point I'm going to
ask you how many people got that joke
how many people know what a mentat is
yes some hands good this is good for me
to know later I would some good market
research for later there were it
pertains to the novel dune by Frank
Herbert anyone read that book okay good
but I was not always a famous miner
television personality a long time ago I
was a member of the book publishing
community I was a professional literary
agent and then a writer of magazine
articles and then a writer of books I
wrote a book a few years ago called the
areas of my expertise which was a
compendium of complete world knowledge
oh thank you thank you you will get your
$25.00 thank you very much sir I
appreciate that and it was it was a book
of amazing true facts and historical
trivia and lists of trivia which was
distinct from other trivia books and
that all of the amazing true facts in my
book were made up by me
and I would be remiss if I did not
mention that I've written a new book
which is something of a follow-up to
this one that includes all sorts of
information about the upcoming
presidential election including the
inner workings of the electoral college
it's actually a very fine College
although that the town of electoral is a
[ __ ]
and the habits and cultures of the mole
men how and when to buy a car fast facts
about Teddy Roosevelt that sort of thing
it has a book called more information
than you require people ask me is it a
sequel to your previous book I say no it
is in fact a direct continuation indeed
the page numbers of the new book pick up
where the last page numbers left off
thus maximizing the confusion potential
among the buyers potential buyers of the
book people ask me why did you write a
new book I mean after all you are now a
famous minor television personality
surely surely your life has changed
dramatically and you don't need to have
truck with books but in fact I still
have a fondness for books in the book
world many of time I will be antiquing
because I do that quite a bit and I'll
be wandering through and out so what's
that old timey curio over there in the
corner was that some sort of candlestick
telephone or one of those old pull chain
toilets oh no that's a book I remember
those I used to help make those things I
think I will and then I will buy it and
use it to decorate my chain of family
casual dining restaurants that I've
started put it up on the wall with old
awooga horns and old street signs that I
use Oh Hajj my hands my family dining
restaurant good time place for drinking
we call it but in fact something
reminded me recently that books are not
just for putting on the wall and that
they have power and appeal beyond that I
was flying as I often do from New York
to the city of Los Angeles and I did not
bring anything with me to read because
why why would you ever bring something
to read on a plane I'm just gonna be
sitting for six hours in a chair I don't
need anything to read I know that I will
be fully stimulated the entire time soon
soon they will turn on the screen and
I'll get to watch episodes of Two and a
Half Men
if you are in business class or first
class as I often travel you they'll give
you a little a little DVR device and you
can you know watch movies that you
didn't mean to see the first time and
you can watch them again or you can
listen to your own portable
entertainment device what's that one
that I like so much
that's that portable entertainment
device that I enjoy oh that my iPod or
iPhone for example that I enjoy so very
much and I knew that I would have you
know lots and lots to entertain me on my
flights to Los Angeles but then disaster
struck we went into that dark territory
where they tell you to turn off all
electronic devices and sit there
unstimulated usually for 10-15 minutes
and you can usually white-knuckle your
way through it
but in this case we were stuck on the
runway for two and a half hours we were
I think 37th in line to take off and at
that point I realized that I had a real
problem because I couldn't have anything
to read and my seatmate
then did something pretty remarkable now
before I go on with this story I need to
ask you a question is the actor and
director Peter Berg in the audience by
any chance no no Peter Berg good then I
can go on so I realized that I was
sitting next to the actor and director
Peter Berg
whom I remembered from such films as
late for dinner and the TV show Chicago
hope but more recently has been
directing movies he's got a Will Smith
movie called Hancock coming out looks
very promising so he was sitting there
and he reaches into his leather backpack
and he pulls out a copy of the novel
dune by Frank Herbert and at this point
my desire to read is so great and I love
that book so much I could not contain
myself I turned to him and I said Peter
Berg that is awesome
I wish I had a copy of dune to read on
this flight right now and Peter Berg
turned to me and he said do you want one
I've got two copies and I I was shocked
and I said Peter Berg
actor and director why do you have two
copies of dim and then he looked at me
and raised an eyebrow and said because
I'm thinking about turning it into a
movie and then this put me in a somewhat
awkward position for as Peter Berg then
began to talk about the movie he was
going to make of dune and showed me
charts of you know the top-selling top
grossing movies of the past ten years
being based on science fiction epics or
or the rings and you know Harry Potter
and everything else and that there is a
obviously a an appetite for these epic
stories based on books I was not aware
whether Peter Berg was aware that dune
had already been made into a movie two
times the first that we all know David
Lynch's remarkable version is actually
one of my favorite movies because
everything and everyone in it is sexy
and deformed at the same time very
interesting interpretation of the book
and then a longer and somewhat more
faithful interpretation
one could argue by the sci-fi channel
some years later and I didn't know if
Peter Berg even knew that had been made
one time and that and that put me in a
very difficult position because no
matter what any chart tells you dune is
more than a sci-fi epic people had tried
and failed to make this into a movie
many times and I knew that he would fail
as well
it is not just a sci-fi epic that can be
adapted into a film it is also a
deranged multi-generational ecological
parable slash drug novel that is sexy
and deformed at the same time but even
worse it is a book it contains sweeps of
time that no movie can ever capture it
contains a level of interior tea that
movies have a very difficult time
capturing their books are not bound to a
single viewing in a single stretch of
time they can be revisited pondered re
seen and reimagined and reconsidered
upon every reading and as well dune
contains giant sand worms they eat sand
and defecate psychedelic drugs and
because when you are reading this this
unfolds in the imagination this idea is
provocative and interesting and cool
instead of just looking ridiculous when
you see it on the screen and so while
dune isn't something of an extreme
example it is true that all books are
this way and that is why I knew Peter
Berg was probably going to fail it could
very well become the white whale of his
career that he would chase and chase and
try to do correctly until finally he
followed it to his doom if you didn't
quite catch that that as an allusion to
Moby Dick a very famous movie now I have
hope I have faith maybe Peter Berg's
version of dune would be a noble failure
and interesting or fun exercise might be
great but it would still fail in the way
all movies that are based on books are
essentially failures even great movies
just as all books are written for the
sole purpose of becoming movies also
fail the only exception I may suggest
however is books of fake trivia such as
the areas of my expertise or more
information than you require both of
those will make terrific movies and the
rights are available and as we got to
talking it turned out that Peter Berg
knew very well that there had been not
one but two versions of dune and he was
going to try it again but at least he
was going into it with eyes open and so
I could relax and we could get drunk
together and enjoy first class and we
never did get that second copy of dune
out of his bag for it was safe down
there and
backpack he and I could do it no harm
and no matter what the book remains I
say this because though it's evident
it's sometimes easy to forget and while
it may sound like I'm congratulating an
industry that I still somewhat consider
my own I'm really congratulating and
thanking all of you the writers and
publishers and especially of course the
booksellers who keep us in business
conjuring worlds that cannot ever be
seen but are often as real as this one
or more so it's my great pleasure to
share this enormous freezing room with
you and to share the stage with with
these amazing and intimidating guests
our first speaker this morning is Ted
Turner we all know yes I think it would
be a pause is appropriate there for sure
we all know Ted Turner as a remarkably
successful entrepreneur and generous
philanthropist he created 24-hour cable
news thus allowing everyone at The Daily
Show to have a job so thank you for your
gift but I have to confess it wasn't
until I reviewed the catalog copy for
his new book call me Ted that I that I
really was able to familiarize myself
with all his many amazing
accomplishments you probably know that
he won the America's Cup in 1977 that's
their bullet point number one he also
pledged to donate a billion dollars to
the United Nations causes
he owns approximately two million acres
of land which according to this is more
than Delaware and Rhode Island combined
which is impressive in itself but
especially so when you consider that
anytime you combine Rhode Island with
any other state they both get smaller
for some reason which explains what's
happening in Connecticut right now also
owns the largest private herd of bison
in America fifty thousand head which is
considerably more bison than I on I have
to say trim size of the book six by nine
the best rights offered world bed
marketing and a twelve copy floor
display with a special riser now
I love 12 copy floor displays but I'm
telling you sir if I own 50 thousand
head of bison I'd take this catalog copy
tape it to every bison and then stampede
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming Ted turn
thank you John thank you boy this is
really a pleasure for me because sob I
haven't hit a home run in a long time
and I think this book's gonna be one and
I'll be back on top you know for in a
relatively new field but it's not a
completely new field because if you'll
recall about 15 years ago I decided the
Turner Broadcasting needed a publishing
division we started Turner publishing on
it everybody here has bought some of
those books remember Dinah topia we
published over a hundred books including
the book that I think sold the least
copies of any book in the history of
American American literary works and
that was that the Vatican Bible that we
I think it was over a thousand dollars
for a Bible and it was in Latin you know
I mean no wonder nobody bought I mean
really truly a collector's item but I
think we still have a few in inventory
if you'd like to move them out but
anyway Turner publishing what when I
merged with Time Warner it went in and
and Turner publishing was moved over in
the Turner and into Time Warner books
and and and disappeared but but it was
there for a while and there's still a
lot of fine fine fine books it table
that with it that we were involved
involved with and I I also was on the
board of Time Warner when they sold sold
the publishing division and I was the
one vote against that and I spoke for
syphilis Lee and I said at the at the
board meeting where they made that
decision they also sold half of the half
of Comedy Central that they owned and I
was so mad about that I screamed bloody
murder I'm not there anymore obviously
but they would have a lot better but
they would have been a lot smarter to
keep me I can tell you that anyway they
say so rabbit but I said a major media
company should have a publishing
division you know books are so important
and will continue to be and but but at
any rate they went ahead and sold it so
uh so I quit
yes that was odd I quit in protest
anyway uh this is all in the book this
is all in the book there's a light this
book I wrote just like I'm a kind of an
informal person and the title call me
Ted
here because a lot of people say cuz I'm
69 years old I'll be 70 this fall in
fact I'll be 76 days after the book the
book comes out so it's my birthday
present to myself but it's very you know
call me Ted it's I'm a very informal law
informal person and it's like this book
is like you're gonna be right there with
me when all this stuff happened I mean
starting seeing in the Gulf War Rob
winning the World Series managing for a
day how many people in the room have
managed a major league baseball team how
many people in this room have been on
all seven continents in one year I mean
really seriously Antarctica you've got
to go to Australia and Antarctica to do
it that's uh I asked Kofi and I on the
general secretary of the United Nations
or the secretary-general pardon me if
he'd been an all law because if you
would think that the head of the UN
would get around the whole world dog and
he'd never been to Australia Antarctica
at all when I asked him I think he has
body he may not have made it day in
Arctica Antarctica is a tough place to
get to to law you can't fly there on
commercial flights anyway
anyway the book I think you're gonna
really like it I'm just sorry that
they've got it under under wraps till
til later on because if you could read a
copy of it now I think you'd buy more of
them you'd order more because you don't
want to run out I don't want you to run
Alan but this not this is not something
I'm doing primarily for money because
even though I did lose six billion
dollars in the AOL merger I still got
the billion and a half two billion left
depending on the value of my land and
I'm not missing any meals or anything I
didn't really need the couple million
dollars that is coming in from this I
really did it to kind of set the record
straight and just to share my
experiences with people because they've
been so amazing so I just hope that
you'll just you know glance at it just
read the first chapter and then if you
don't like it you know but I think most
of you will read it and you're really
going to enjoy it and that's the main
thing and there's there's a lot of
lessons in there for young people like
there's a chapter on integrity once say
you remember Ted Turner never got
indicted like those guys from Enron and
those saw cooking I never cheated at
least I never got caught cheating all my
taxes or
I won't say I never got caught cheating
on my wives either but not much but
there's not there's not much of that I
have I have evolved five children
one of them's here and and 11
grandchildren and I didn't want to
embarrass him like Barbara Walters has
done I left my personal life pretty well
out of the book God and and and I
because I just didn't want to embarrass
my family but I didn't really do
anything that bad anyway I'm I never
messed with any children and I never was
a polygamist like those people Wow you
know I hope they get their kids back
don't you you know I saw a big news
story right now
okay well I think we can do the Q&A I
think I've done with the formal part of
my presentation
so there's gonna be the QA and I guess
the way that this is going to work is
that there are people roaming the aisles
with microphones and if you would speak
here is one of them and if you indicate
that you have a question that person
will come around and you will ask the
question and as need be I will restate
it first of all I'm sure that a lot of
us have had our luggage go to all seven
continents the same year on the
collection he just made a joke pretend
to laughter we made a joke that our
luggage go to all seven continents but
not ourselves our luggage is confident
his question was could you comment on
the current election your opinion about
the current election e'en on the current
election it's a mess he said that it's a
mess no matter what happens there's
gotta be a lot of unhappy people the
thing about it is to me is I know the
United States we send all these monitors
to go over and check on the elections
and all these little third-world
countries and we're always complaining
that they're having elections that are
all screwed up and and our elections is
screwed up as much as anybody else's I
mean we are a one man and woman one vote
this is [ __ ] you're here I believe
they said I don't even know who's gonna
win and I was ran CNN for 25 years I
believe have a question over here my
name is Michael J Herman I'm the
publisher of the damn syndicated column
the motivational minute and my question
for you is in the life that you've led
so amazing so ubiquitous it and so
transformational what stands out as the
single or a couple of being most
meaningful and rezoning moments in your
life boy some of the most a couple of
the most meaningful and resounding
moments in your amazing life I was in
Los Angeles the day that the Gulf War
started and I was at Jane's house and
she was out working it was in the
afternoon it was primetime in the east
and the war started while I was saw
while I had to tell her
to CNN and I flipped over to CBS and
there was dan Rather talking and then I
flipped over to ABC and there was Peter
Jennings talking [ __ ] over to NBC and
that was broke are talking foot back to
see it in and there was the war dice
come up from a business standpoint that
was that was my greatest thrill and and
and my personal greatest thrill was
making love the first time leave we have
a question over here sir what is your
name sir
my name is Mike Robbins Mike Robbins go
ahead what's your what's your take on
the current state of the media that
24-hour cable news what's your
perspective I'll tell you I'm sorry what
is your take on the current state of the
media 24-hour number to cover in a bit
read the book and you'll get a little
bit a little bit of that do you think
that the Daily Show should be on CNN
International by any chance hold you
that I love it I love this show but I
don't think it belongs on a serious news
network are there are there sizes like a
lot are there serious news networks
there used to be but not anymore
the last night Larry King who I dearly
love my good friend hosted the party he
had American Idol people on for the
whole hour I mean you know here we are
in the middle of the war and of election
and we're America and I I it's just that
trivialization of the news I think it's
important that there be one place
somewhere in the world that you can turn
on and get serious news all the time
I would I would like to think it was CNN
we have a question over here sir hi I'm
Victor Brown I'm from Atlanta Georgia
and grew up in love with channel 17 and
turning all the things you did so I just
wanted to tell you how proud I am of
that and I want to ask you a question
about as you look at the landscape with
everything happening with Facebook and
LinkedIn and a lot of the technologies
does it really mind you some of the
things you did when you went 24 hours
with news and cable the gentleman from
Atlanta asks what your opinion is of
MySpace and Facebook and all the social
networking sites and does it remind you
of some of the innovations that you
brought to news when you started 24
hours yes they're very innovative and
now obviously they perform a very
valuable function a lot of people like
them and use them and we're in a we're
in an age of explosion in in media
availability and technology and it's a
very exciting time to be alive I'm just
going to go over here and then we'll
come back yes hi my name is Darcy and
you're going to be 70 and you've already
lived a very vital amazing life thank
you but I'm only 37 my question is is
there still one big dream deal or idea
that you want to accomplish in your life
there's still one big dream deal or idea
that you want to accomplish absolutely I
want to but what I'm mainly working on
now is trying to make the world a better
place by and safer by ridding the world
of nuclear weapons that's the first
thing we need to do we've got to
preserve the environment preserve the
environment and stop global warming by
moving away of redoing our whole
electric garb and transportation system
and moving to clean renewable energy
we've got to stabilize the population
with getting serious about family
planning all over the world and and
we've got to renounce violence and work
together with the rest of the world
through the United Nations there to have
peace and prosperity for everybody
there's no reason why we can't do that
I'm sick of war time for one more yeah
very whatever you're the man
I am will do here and then here I think
yes good morning I'm Cheri Byrd from
Albuquerque New Mexico and I was
wondering if you plan to tour the book
and will the tour include a stop in New
Mexico where you own all that land and
have all the Bison will you be touring
to promote the book and will you go to
New Mexico in particular where the young
woman is I'm gonna I'm gonna did the
publicity plans are being worked out but
for instance I did the audio book myself
it took me over 20 hours to do and I put
my crazy ass minute I think it's gonna
really be popular we'll see but I'm
gonna do some touring I just don't know
how much but I'm gonna do I'm going to
work hard to make this book a success
because I'm really very proud of it and
it's a story that I think people will
really enjoy and over here there was
another question good morning my name is
Siobhan Moran I have a question about
you've taken a lot of risks in your life
yes
I've taken a lot of risks in your life
yeah so as an entrepreneur how would you
suggest one get over fear of taking that
next risk as an entrepreneur how would
you say the one should get over the fear
of risk any tricks for getting over
you've got it you've got it
you got a know when to hold read the
book and you'll learn off thank you very
much
thank you Jeff Turner uh when we speak
of the strange and unique power of books
if you understand them so well as an art
excuse me azar Nafisi reading Lolita in
Tehran describes her experience teaching
the works of Nabokov Fitzgerald in
Austin
sometimes in secret in the repressive
regime in Iran after the Revolution it
was a best-seller as you know Michiko
Kakutani described it as an eloquent
brief on the transformation tricks using
the transformative power of fiction
she's also the author of a children's
fable be be in the green voice and now
she has a new book things I've been
silent about a memoir of family she is a
visiting professor at Johns Hopkins
University the School of Advanced
International Studies is that correct in
Washington DC did I get it right almost
okay very well and we were having a
wonderful conversation in the green room
before and I hope and trust that she
will be as thoughtful provocative and
interesting as she was for you now very
well
it's so wonderful to be here and you
know after hearing Ted turn and I
thought already I felt sort of
irrelevant some every time I think of
the title of the book you know me by
reading Lolita in Tehran I think people
wonder I mean who do any of you when you
think of Tehran think of a group of
young girls sitting in a living room
overlooking the mountains eating cream
puffs and talking about Nabokov or Saul
Bellow obviously the image that you have
of Tehran would be mainly of our
wonderful amazing president and you
don't have him in The Daily Show by the
way mr. Ahmadinejad who usually has a
sort of a smirk in his face Anderson
Cooper did a rather good interview with
him not I could have done better sort of
with a smirk on his face as if he has
just broken the neighbours window and
gotten away with it and so it is it is
rather frustrating to think that the
image of a country as Asians with a
culture with the traditions as Iran
comes to us and comes to this country
that I love as my other home with the
images of mr. Katami and mr. Ahmadinejad
and the kind of sort of politicized and
and reductionist and fragmented world
that we live in is the kind of world
that then when you think of America of
course you think of another president
with the sort of a smirk on his face you
know I always tell my friends you should
never go where I go because I went back
to Iran in 1979 to fundamentalism terror
and the war in Iraq and when I chose to
come back to this other home in 1997 I
came back to fundamentalism terror and
the war would Iraq so just don't stay in
LA you don't know what will happen to
you
but at any point what what my life's
mission has been and what has been this
sort of inspiration behind every single
book that I have written has been this
idea of the world of imagination and the
we it poses an alternative view an
alternative way of looking at the world
it creates it becomes a protest against
not just the tyranny of politics but
also the tyranny and the basic
fickleness and Terran tyranny that that
lies at the heart of life and that is
why I feel so much at home in a place
like this you know I think that books
are like your children you go through so
much labor so much pain so much doubt
and anxiety they come to the world you
they leave you go out and you don't know
what amazing places they take you to and
what wonderful intimate strangers they
bring back to your life so in a sort of
a few minutes I want to talk based on
that sort of what some this new book
that I have come up with it has a
pedigree it has sort of a birth
certificate part of it is in the reality
of the life I have lived but always I
think your book has its pedigree in in
the reality in the experiences of the
author and also in the experiences of
all the ghosts of all those other books
and that that that become as much part
of life as well as anything else the
sort of Republic of imagination in which
your you are not limited by by the
limitations of nationality religion
ethnicity race gender and and class and
a man named Rumi I can live side by side
with a woman named Zora Neale Hurston
with a man named Flo bear with a man
named Dennis Lehane and Donald trum all
these men actually sitting on this panel
so in this Republic of imagination you
know when you go to a bookstore or a
library nobody asks you and are you a
new Khan or a liberal before they let
you in whom are you gonna vote for what
do you think about Reverend Wright
before they admit you and in this in
this sort of Republic of imagination
that I think books should be written not
bound by by by any of these limitations
and my my book
that I wrote has two other siblings the
first book that I wrote in Iran was
unbloody muna bakov and by the way it
wouldn't that is not good you you you
will take that back but but um you know
in this window this room you feel I you
talk about democracy but when you're on
the microphone it's it's different but
you can start start coughing and looking
at your friends and I know that it's my
time to leave the podium but but very
fast when I was writing my book on
Vladimir Nabokov um I I wanted to talk
about my obsession is this relationship
between fiction and reality ways through
which fiction perceives the world and
alters the world and relates to the
world and at the same time the way are
different realities at different times
change fiction change our change change
the books they reinterpret them
presented to us as fresh and and so but
I couldn't I couldn't talk about the
reality part of it and it was not just
the political aspects of it it was also
the personal because both the personal
and the political were taken should have
been taken out of my book for example I
wanted to begin my book by saying that
the first time I read Vladimir Nabokov
the first book I read by him was odda
and it was given to me by my boyfriend
Ted and he wrote on the Flyleaf to us
are my other love Ted and I couldn't do
that that would have been impossible so
in my diary I started writing under the
title things I have been silent about
all the things that I had been silent
about that I couldn't talk about and
when you are silent about things you
become complicit even though you're a
victim you become complicit in the crime
that is that is committed even against
you and that is why fiction that is why
imagination that is why talking bringing
out the truth becomes so so essential to
our survival as human beings
and so under that title I had written
about the horrendous experiences of the
executions and murders of dear friends
and relatives and my students Rozier who
they spent the last days in jail talking
about Henry James and and Great Gatsby
before she was executed I don't about
that and then I wrote about the
absurdities because the only sacred in
fiction is the profane it is the power
of humor and irony and looking at
yourself and taking the attitude towards
yourself that is an attitude of humor
and an irony that that makes you survive
and then there were also the funny
things for example in the cartoon of
Popeye that they showed in Iran they cut
olive oil from most things because you
knew that olive oil is a loose woman
that she has an illicit relationship
with Popeye and you know you wouldn't
have here a presence with those
wonderful stockings if I can remember
and then you cut some Desdemona from
most things out of a fellow and and they
cut some and the Othello suicide because
masses get depressed watching Laurence
Olivier commit suicide and on the screen
they don't get depressed when they're
stoned to death on where when they're
married at the age of nine they say
always our culture you know but
apparently they get depressed by that or
they put some scarves on the head of
female chickens in children's books so
that the male chickens don't get too
horny and really sort of jump on them
female chickens now these absurdities
were also part of our lives so I started
making headings for these absurdities
and then saying things like in washing
the forbidden videos in Iran watching we
watched marks brothers day and night all
the Turner Classic Movies we were
watching in our forbidden videos and and
and going to parties in Tehran eating
ice cream in Tehran reading Lolita in
Tehran reading Jane Austen in Tehran and
so when I came here and I want to focus
on this and then sort of wrap it up with
my present book when I
came here I was so amazingly shocked
that the image that you know a
totalitarian state steals your identity
makes you homeless you become for loan
and homeless because all that you are
for example as a woman as a writer as a
student is taken away from you and if
and you become a figment of someone
else's imagination and against this
identity theft the only thing you have
that makes you survive is to be able to
tell your version of the story and when
I came to this country I would go to
places and they say what are you writing
about and I said well I'm writing about
you know all these dead white writers
actually like Nabokov and bellow and
they would say but you have such a
bright future here you should be writing
about Islam and and women and I would
tell them no you write about Islam and
women and I want to write about the
others because literature is always
about the other you should be talking
about Rumi and harvest and bringing a
new perspective to my culture and I
should be talking about bello and Twain
and bringing something new to you and
and and so I started and they would look
at you and they say when you talk about
lowering the age of marriage from
eighteen to nine they would say oh this
is their culture if that is my culture
then burning wishes in Salem is the
culture of this country if that is my
culture then slavery is the culture of
this country and not Nora Neale Hurston
or Frederick Douglas or James Madison or
George Mason if this is my culture then
Inquisition is the culture of Europe and
fascism and communism and not flow Barre
and Dante and Goethe and st. Thomas
Aquinas and st. Augustine every culture
has something to be ashamed of we are
not innocent not a single culture or
nation is innocent but every nation and
culture is proud to bring about change
this country 60 years ago had segregated
grunts this country the women in this
country voted in 1920s Elizabeth Cady
Stanton did not live to see American
women gain the right to vote in
Switzerland they voted in 1967 when we
think of that and when we think that in
these cultures they talked about Bible
says that women should stay at home
Bible says that slavery is good people
should have empathy for the people who
are now trying to gain the right to
choose and the right to live so to make
a very very long story short and I am
making Detroit that was the whole idea
behind my books to remember that my
culture is not is not stoning people to
death my culture is the greatest poets
that any culture can offer like Hoffa's
or or Rumi or hyeyeon poets who used
wine as a symbol of communion with God
and we never call our the places where
we drink and bars we call them the
houses of wine because they relate to
God anyway that is another story so
there are two to end it then as I was
writing the acknowledgements to reading
Lolita to Tara in Tehran my mother died
and all of a sudden that death made me
feel that here is the greatest silence
support against the silence of against
politics against society you can raise
your voice voice what do you do with the
absolute silence of death how do you
deal with oblivion how do you leave
something behind of conclusive evidence
that you have lived that was the main
issue that I had and I had loads of
issues with my mother in many ways she
imposed her figments of imagination on
our realities and especially on me
because I was the first one and I was a
girl and she was an unfinished woman and
she constantly blamed us for being more
finished than she was
and and I realized that literature and
writing is not just about presenting an
alternative view it is finishing a
conversation that leaves unfinished in
reality and now in this book I wanted to
carry on the conversations with my
parents my father having died a year
after she did and and what I realized
was the most difficult battle and the
most interesting battle is fought on the
personal level
no wonder fiction is all about the
personal relationships and the
individuals is a celebration of life and
the extraordinary rest of the ordinary
and I discovered how courageous my
parents were in public he was the mayor
of Tehran and went to jail for four
years without a trial because he opposed
the government and she was the first
woman among the first six women to go to
Congress some Parliament in Iran in
early 1960s both of them were outrageous
and outspoken where they showed
cowardliness and betrayal and and will
bewildered it was in the domain of the
personal and I so I wanted to talk about
that and that that might not may be my
last silence but my more most important
silence so I want to end my talk by
saying that my parents in this book that
the main topic of my book is how
homeless my parents were and as the
German philosopher Theodor Adorno says
the highest form of morality is not to
feel at home in your own home in this
country I think this is very very
relevant today whenever you feel smart
and you think you know where you are and
you are at home I think that is where
the danger comes and so they were
homeless and that homelessness in real
life was very difficult for us but one
thing they left me with was stories when
ever since I was three years old my
father would tell me stories he would
tell me that my country was invaded and
conquered so many many many times and
the only thing we have the only thing we
have that gives us the name Iran is this
poet
is its language and and he will tell us
the stories of the great epic poet
Ferdowsi and and I realize now coming to
this other home that the only true home
I have is the portable home off of my
imagination and so on that note and on
the note of portable home I just would
like to end and to say that writing
about my parents as any form of writing
is both a declaration of independence
about from them and from the reality you
talk about and the homage to that
reality despite all its pains and
anguish and and and and that literature
is never a consolation or an aspirin
that literature is always a protest and
a resistance against both tyranny of
colonists and time and thank you for
your
I'm the PC thank you so much for making
us feel
making us feel at home and so not at
home at the same time this is actually
very much like my home this room I have
it set up pretty much the same way it's
a little bigger than this a little
colder our third and final speaker today
is Dennis Lehane of course Dennis Lehane
has had his own experience seeing the
giant sandworms of his imagination
translated to the screen but usually
with much more successful results the
oscar-winning and nominated Mystic River
and Gone Baby Gone
and through his all of his novels he
conjures a Boston that is a city of
small nodded communities separated by
class and race and profession yet
intimately entangled together and often
tested by wrenching tragedy with his new
novel the given day Lehane looks back to
that city's past to the 1919 police
strike the beginning of prohibition the
end of World War 1 all the cultural and
social upheavals that surrounded those
events and its epic and dizzying and
vast but it is also small once it gets
into the brains of a dizzyingly diverse
array of characters from black baseball
players to Irish cops to the sort of
whiskey addled sad and beautiful brain
of Babe Ruth who it turns out was an
actual historical figure actually a real
person apparently a baseball player
look that up on Wikipedia and it's when
in those tiny personal moments that are
so beautifully and perfectly rendered in
the novel that the story really gets big
so it's my pleasure to welcome Dennis
Slamon
I just want to thank whoever came up
with the brilliant idea of having me
follow these three that's just grace
particularly after I've been out of the
limelight now for five years working on
this wonderful I believe our publication
today called it doorstop thank you very
much
five years working on a novel I looked
like rusty yesterday actually I shaved
for the first time so yes I'm following
this is and I'm still back I'm sorry I
got to go back to this for just one
moment
I've been sitting for the last 10
minutes going a fellow without Desdemona
how do you do a fellow without Desdemona
I mean what's the motive for anything
there's this handkerchief this is just
the most absurd thing I've heard in a
long time by the way if you can YouTube
since we're all into YouTube going to
YouTube to Eddie Izzard talking and
doing his imitation of Christopher
Walken doing Yago it's one of the
funniest things I have ever seen
he's like a fellow your wife
I think you should strangle it with a
pillow so yes I have just gone back from
the wilderness five years after to write
a book about Boston police strike I'll
speak a little bit about that in a
minute
it is a doorstop but by god it's fun
it's fun on every page it's it's a
veritable page-turner what is what is
the new I think Larry King may have
started this wonderful destruction of
our English language I think he was the
first person to say this
it's unput it down a bowl I thought it
was interesting that the John brought up
right off the bat
two and a Half Men which is one of my
favorite shows i watch it just to see
what shirt Charlie's gonna wear it is it
is okay we all I've sat through enough
publishing conversations in the last 12
years to know how they go and they often
go basically to sad fact the underlying
subtext of all of them is that the
lowest-rated rerun of Two and a Half Men
the one where Jon Cryer was injured so
Charlie how to handle it alone
that will be watched by more people than
will ever read The Kite Runner or Gilead
or Moby Dick guaranteed but here's what
everybody seems to forget no one
remembered that two and a Half Men
episode no one no one remembers who won
American Idol ten years from now I can
guarantee it unless that's a J guys
still around no no one's gonna remember
what happened on whatever sitcom they
watched last week
never mind a month from now this is is
the difference between passive and
active entertainment books are active
entertainment books will endure at some
level I am a writer because of libraries
I'm the softest touch
world for libraries I have spoken at
libraries thank you
I have spoken at libraries truly in in
the [ __ ] of the world for no money
and paid my own plane fare because when
I was six years old my mother took me to
a library my mother was she was an
immigrant from Ireland we had no books
in my house except for some very ancient
encyclopedia Britannica's that still
called Vietnam Indochina it was just
basically the one day my father must
have been drinking and just didn't see
the salesman coming so here I was the
youngest of five children and I just
knew that I really liked reading and my
mother took me walked me this well I was
the the library in my town was right at
the sort of place where the sort of
nexus of of class and race warfare in
the city of Boston right at the time
when busing was about to begin so it was
an education for a child to walk to that
library pretty much every day which is
what I did and was to walk through a
sort of racial and ethnic a war zone as
as federal desegregation in the Boston
Public Schools got more and more violent
but that's what I did because that's
where my mother took me because she knew
that if I like books that meant
something that books meant something
that books meant a way out much like a
public school much like a public college
so she took me to the library when I was
six because the nuns told me told her
that I like to read so I went and I got
a book and I'll still I'll tie it to
this day
when the first book I ever read was Ted
Turner may remember his first sexual
experience and I do too
but I also remember my first book my
first book was Smokey the Bear and it's
it was a sequel but because I think the
third in a series so I had to go back
but it was Smokey the Bear and here's
what was so impressive about it I was
six right and it's said on the inside
page remember looking at this said for
ages eight and up six and write
precocious even then so yes so I I read
Smokey the Bear and from that point on I
went back to this library every day I
was a complete addict I have been to
seven continents to John and I have also
owned a baseball team together but I
have been to seven continents I just did
it via books I have been to a dozen or
so planets I have been all over the
world I have been in the bodies of all
different types of people I've done this
all through books it is interesting to
me that we stand up here all of us today
and somebody asked again I'm sorry I
keep I keep picking it on mr. Turner
because I'm never gonna be able to do it
again
somebody asked Ted Turner what in the
audience said so what would you've done
everything with your like everything
with your life I mean my god I would
like to be Ted Turner's fingernail for
just a day everything with your life
what are you going to do what what
haven't you done well guess what he
hadn't done in written a book everybody
wants to write a book everybody at the
end of the day it's the ultimate thing
producers I know producers out in
Hollywood they're always just like you
know if you ever get a chance to talk to
your publisher you know these guys are
worth like a hundred million dollars you
know they got you know interchangeable
women everywhere who are quite cute and
and they say cuz you know what I really
want to do is write you know if you
could maybe hook me up with your editor
you know I got this great idea and it's
usually a really bad idea but that you
know it's it's I think I rift on it and
one of my stories there's it's usually
something like well there's this priest
and he he he dies but his soul comes
back but it's been perverted and he
becomes a counterterrorism expert and
and I just think it could be a real hit
you know so everyone yes wants to write
a book I did not necessarily want to
write a book it became a naturally
organic process let me tell you exactly
how I became a writer when I was 20
years old I dropped out of to colleges
to colleges to safety managers and I
made this um I had this moment of
reckoning with myself where I realized I
needed to be a writer because I sucked
at everything else there is not a single
thing I'm good at I do not have a hobby
I do not have any skills I have only one
thing in the world I seem to do this
storytelling thing kind of okay so I
went to my parents who were Irish
immigrants who had watched their only
son to go to college drop out of both of
them they were so proud and and I said
to them I said I I think I should go and
get a Creative Writing degree um and and
they they didn't know what that was and
they still don't
but they said well you do pretty much
suck at everything else so do you think
you could get a scholarship and I said I
think I could you know and I did I got a
scholarship and I went off to school and
I'll never forget my mother saying the
one thing my mother said she said well
when you get this creative writing
degree will you be able to teach and I
and I didn't know what you better so I
said sure
no creative writing degree basically
prepares you to do exactly one thing get
a masters and creative writing and
that's you bastards you know I mean you
guys could show up on some campuses
every now and then you know what I mean
trying to recruit people to be
sub-editors you know where's the New
Yorker when you need them no I went and
graduated college with the Creative
Writing degree and promptly got a job
working at a liquor store so then I I
kept writing as as believing as I did
that there were people out there who
would care ultimately if I could write
something good I still believe that no I
do otherwise I wouldn't be here sue I'll
never got to New York well I published a
book or two I'm gonna skip forward here
I got to New York and I remember having
this conversation with my editor and my
agent at the time when I said uh who are
still my editor my agent by the way I
don't know why I said at the time I'm
not one of those I don't have them
strewn all over the place like ex-wives
same editor and agents since the
beginning [ __ ] so I sat down with my
editor Claire walk to Ellen my agent and
written Burton and I I said I just want
to be really clear and sort of the
career plan here to understand that I
will never ever write a best-seller it's
not it's not my thing
and and they kind of you know the same
look my parents gave me when I you know
you suck at everything else there's kind
of yeah we kind of get that you know
you're not
but they they sort of agreed with me but
I look back in retrospect now and I
realize I'm in business almost entirely
with women I don't work too well with
men every now and then I do but the
problem with men is they're always
trying to whip it out and so am I so it
just doesn't go well there's too much
testosterone in the room I have realized
now many years later my agent and I
entered on't think I know this but I
realized that that I work well with
women because I'm easily manipulated by
them so they ultimately said sure in a
problem we know you won't have a best
sell you go off and do that creative
thing that you do and and they did let
me allow me to to create my career as I
wanted to create my career that I
couldn't do a book a year I couldn't
tell you what I was gonna write from one
week to the next
Oh at the height of a successful series
at the moment my detective series became
successful I said well well I'm done
with that now I'm gonna go run off and
write a Russian influence depressing
book about a small-town tragedy in a
fictitious Dorchester town I mean Boston
town they said oh great idea
good so I did that and then I was
tricked in a sense into having a
best-seller my fat book mr. grubber
became my best seller and here's what
happened my publisher called me this
didn't happen I'm Michael Morrison
called me up on the phone and said this
book is amazing it's gonna it's gonna
become a best-seller and I said I don't
know what you're smoking but this book
will never be a best-seller this and he
was like why I said because basically I
was married at the time my first wife
said you could call this book everybody
loses and it's true
it's true you think about it everybody
in that book just loses you know so you
know they catch the murderer but they're
wrong you know he kills the guy who
killed his daughter but hoops
it was the wrong guy it's not a happy
book and they say oh this is gonna be a
best-seller and I say you're crazy
and it's a best-seller why was it a
best-seller because they believed in it
because they loved it because
they wanted to spread that love it's the
best old-fashioned way that anything
becomes successful I don't think
necessarily that that happens in film I
could be missing something
I know for a fact that it doesn't happen
in TV most times except on the wire but
it that is the beauty of of publishing
is that somebody said I love this I'm
gonna make somebody else fall in love
with this and I know that if I have a
good enough I don't even want to call it
product there's too many people talk
about product in this business today if
we have a good enough work to go out
with we can make people believe in that
that still exists in in this business
this this thing of ours this little
Maffeo of ours and most when we worry
when we sit there and we we stress out
about Oh what's gonna happen in the age
of YouTube what's gonna happen in the
age of computers what's gonna happen
what's gonna happen the age of
conglomeration what's gonna happen in
the age of super bookstores what's gonna
happen and all of you know all of this
are we going to lose the book seems to
be the question is the book going to
vanish is the book going to end is the
book going to be as john said a curio
that you find in the back of a of a
store yes no it's not gonna happen um
and I'll tell you why most permutations
of narrative art are just that there are
the permutations they're the offshoots
books are the genesis of narrative art
we are where it began and they will
always always endure because there will
always be people out there who need
active engagement with their narrative
art active engagement with their source
material is that going to be the large
part of the population no the large part
of the population friggin voted for Bush
in the second election
or Schwarzenegger you know absolutely
not but we're not absolutely we're not
looking for the vast majority of the
population if we were we would be in
film or we would be in TV
we're in books we're in something that
is going to endure we are in something
that is going to connect with exactly
the people we most wanted to connect to
and it will continue very slowly very
subtly but it will continue to change
the world and that is what you guys do
and that's what we all do so oh I'm done
Thank You Dennis Lehane everybody his
book is not is not a doorstop it can
also be used pressed and pates or to
keep small children from blowing away in
the wind this concludes our breakfast
please join me in thanking Ted Turner
azar Nafisi
Jennifer Haines thank you so much
thank you so much for such a warm
reception at this grimaced of ours this
is the first baa I've ever been to and I
have to say it's been really very
inspiring visiting with so many
booksellers and especially what we all
our book readers and book lovers
it really makes even the Staples Center
feel like the Javits Center thank you
very much